when was the last time that you were
actually sick with amazement what when
was the last time you were actually
white with sheer terror probably unless
you've been caught in automobile
accident sir landslides it was a
psychedelic experience because these
things deliver
authentic emotions authentic data and
the the bottom bit of history is that it
D potentiates human dividuals just in
order to live inside the historical
society you have to stop yourself down
and down and down you mustn't be in
other people's face you mustn't thrust
your ethnicity or your gender your
tattoo or whatever it is - you mustn't
flaunt everything is confined this is
the attitude of history it's what's
called being part of the public it's
something necessary for democracies to
do business
there has to be a public but when we
identified with the public we
essentially become creatures of the herd
and there is no peace until the
there is no leather and crack sure until
the end as we approach the
transcendental object at the end of time
history moves faster and faster
we have been approaching this
transcendental object since before there
was a way to speak of in human terms in
other words this is the same attractor
that holds life out of the oceans cause
primates to stand on their hind legs and
so forth and so on but obviously pick a
number about 20,000 years ago ten
thousand years ago the process pretend
we turned the corner everything began to
move faster and again at the fall of
Rome
faster faster and again in the 20th
century faster faster faster
well nobody has drawn the obvious
conclusion from this if we're going
faster and faster faster and faster that
hell we're gonna get somewhere pretty
soon
and and that's where I think we are we
can hardly go any faster without the
speed of our acceleration passing into
the domains of humanely cognizable time
in other words the reason things are
getting weirder and weirder is because
the space-time continuum itself is
accelerating it's entirely possible that
the last half of the life of the
universe will happen in about 3% of the
total life of the universe nobody said
that it has to take as long going down
as it took to come up it may be that the
coming up took the long time and the
going down can be catastrophic sudden
unexpected dynamic we say and that's why
I take and I return to this thing
because
and I returned to all the things that
history is an anticipation history is
the last call that the train is leaving
the station
you know the colleg goes back to chattel
philia and slightly beyond but in our
own lifetime it's now palpable you know
all you have to do is close your eyes in
a quiet place twist up a bomber please
and you will behold the transcendental
object at the end of time you can feel
it in form in your own life I mean you
spend a good deal of time denying it
because rationalist tell you you're
either losing your mind or it's
impossible and it can't be happening
but this sense of plotted nosaka nected
Nastase sense that we are all in a
universal drama playing to a close this
sense that we are larger than ourselves
that we are somehow characters on a
stage this is a phenomenon of the light
at Eventide this is a phenomenon of the
final moments of the
make drama and I think it's tremendously
exciting I think this is what make sure
set about 700 million years ago on this
planet that it's not about chipmunk
after 2 month after chipmunk for Yonder
he'll I mean a little of that goes a
long ways I'm sure you'll agree with me
that's all very fine but the way nature
works is she builds upon her complexity
we can feel that we're more than animals
we have this dimension which we call
spiritual which and some of us buy it
which is some off-the-shelf explanation
Catholicism or - Janus of something like
that others of us wrestle with it or we
smart this board it and - you know a
little table a little Taoism
little Tantra little hafsat ISM it
doesn't do that but whatever it is we
wrestle with this part of ourselves
which cannot be simply dismissed
there is monkey meat and I think that it
is
[Music]
the soul that the soul is actually as an
entity in history seeking to be born and
that the enterprise of history is the
creation of the collectivity as an
eternal indestructible transdimensional
object of some sort the tool at the end
of time
[Music]